who is the Speaker of the House and what  do they do the office of the Speaker of  the House is actually outlined in the  Constitution that's one of the things  that makes the Speaker of the House  unique the Speaker of the House does not  have to be a member of the House  although there has never been a speaker  who has not been a member of the House  and traditionally the Speaker of the  House is the member picked by the  majority party doesn't have to be from  the majority party but that's always the  way it's worked out and essentially  everybody in the house gets together and  whoever gets the most votes of the  people voting it's just the people  voting not necessarily the entire house  whoever gets the most votes becomes the  Speaker of the House